[موسيقى]
طابع مساؤكم نحييكم واليكم نشره التاسعه
هذا المساء وهذه عناوينها
هجمات اوكرانيه على محاور الشرق كيف تتحدث
عن تقدم واسكت تؤكد احباطها
بعد واشنطن عقوبات اوروبيه قريبه وخطر
الفيضانات يزيد متاعب السودانيين
الذكاء الاصطناعي يستقطب اكثر من 12 مليار
دولار باتجاه خزائن شركات التكنولوجيا
حرب بين مرشحي الحزب الجمهوري ترامبوا
ديسانتس في مرمى هيلي وفانس يتصيد اخطاء
رئيسه السابق
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره دفاع روسيه خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه جراء الهجوم واسع نطاق الذي
شنته على خمس قطاعات من منطقه جنوب
اوكرانيا الخسائر بحسب الوزاره الروسيه
بلغت 250 فردا وسته عشره دبابه واحد
وعشرين مركبه قتال المتحدث باسم وزاره
دفاع قال ان القوات الروسيه تتصدت لهجوم
الاوكرانيا واسع النطاق على خمس قطاعات من
الجبهه تم تكتم مطبق تحيطه اوكرانيا
بهجومها المضاد صاحب الحرب واقع لا تريدها
ان يستاثر بخططها ويساعد العدو باي طريقه
باصابع موضوعه على افواههم روج الجنود
الاوكرانيون لصمت عمليتهم المقبله وجددوا
مطالبتهم بالتزام السريه حيالها فوزاره
الدفاع نفت وجود اعلان عن بدايه الهجوم
مضيفه ان الخطط تحب الصمت لا بل شنت حمله
على المواطنين الذين ينشرون صورا او لقطات
لمنظومات الدفاع وهي تسقط صواريخ روسيه
التركيز على عدم افشاء موعد الهجوم يعود
الى اهميه عنصر المفاجاه في الحروب بحسب
خبراء وقد تكون لتصريحات الاوكرانيه
المتضاربه الاثر الاكبر فرئيس الاوكراني
اكد جهوزيه قواته للهجوم المضاد بعد ايام
من اعلان تاجيل الهجوم
على الرغم من عدم وضوح الرؤيه فيما اذا
كانت اوكرانيا قد بدات بالفعل هجوم المضاد
من عدمه دعونا نلقي معكم الضوء على ما حدث
في الساعات الماضيه في مقاطعه وفقا لروايه
روسيه الدفاع الروسيه قالت انها صدت هجوما
ضخما للقوات الاوكرانيه عبر خمس نقاط
جنوبي طبعا واحده من اربع مناطق اوكرانيه
ضمتها روسيا الخليفه الماضي تشمل
لوغانسكون القوات الاوكرانيه بحسب تصريحات
الدفاع الروسيه استخدمت ست كتائب
ميكانيكيه وكتبتي دبابات في الهجوم وبينما
نفت موسكو ان تكون كيف قد نجحت في اختراق
دفاعاتها في القطاع الاكثر ضعفا حيث
تتصاعد المواجهات منذ اشهر اوكرانيا اكتفت
والتي غيرت تكتيكاتها العسكريه اخيرا بشن
هجمات متفرقه داخل العمق الروسي اكتفت
باعلاني تقدم قواتها البريه في دانيتسكو
وبالتحديد في مواقع قرب مدينه التي فرضت
قوات فاجن الروسيه سيطرت عليها الشهر
الماضي
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى كيف ومعلم هناك الصحفي محمد
البابا محمد اهلا بك معنا في التاسعه هذا
المساء كيف تتحدث عن تقدم عسكري في محاور
الشرق في ماموسكو هذا الهجوم وتؤكد احباطه
فما حقيقه ما يجري في هذه المناطق
بالتحديد
تقدمت القوات الاوكرانيه واستطاعت كما
يعني خرج بيان هيئه الاركان العامه
استطاعت نسف وضرب خطوط الدفاع الاولى
للقوات الروسيه فيزا مصادر وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه تنفي يعني هي لم تخرج في
الاعلام بشكل بشكل رسمي ولكن ما يتداول
تنفي ما نشرته روسيا عن مقتل 250 جندي في
دونيس وتدمير 16 دبابه وتسع مركبات اليه
تقول ان هذه ضمن الدعايه لضرب معنويات
الاوكرانيين في يعني اللحظات الاولى
للهجوم تمام طب محمد بلدي جعلك اكثر جراه
في هجماتها الاخيره على الاراضي الروسيه
في السابق كانت تتخذ في موقع الدفاع اليوم
الهجوم ماذا يدور اوكرانيا
لكن يعني هناك نقطه اساسيه هناك قريه
قريتين بالكامل تحت سيطره
المتطوعين الروس التابعون لاوكرانيا في
مقاطعه وحتى قبل حوالي نصف ساعه خرج حاكم
انقطعت
بيد القوات ببيد قوات ما يسمى بروسيا
الحره او المتطوعين الروس بعد خروج القوات
الروسيه من تلك المنطقه ومقتل قائد القوات
العسكريه للجيش الروسي في مقاطعه بعد
استهدافه بمسيره في تلك المدينه يمكن
القول هناك تحرك خطير ان تكون يعني مساحه
جغرافيه من الاراضي الروسيه اصبحت بيد
المتطوعين الروس يعني الموالين لاوكرانيا
ايضا الان هو يعني كما يتداول بدا الهجوم
المضاد لم تعلن اوكرانيا بشكل رسمي
باستثناء تصريحان هذا ينقلنا الان الى
الواقع الهجومي الاوكرانيا وبعد حوالي 87
اشهر من الاستعداد والتدريب وارسال بعثات
وجنود الى الدول الاجنبيه الى الدول
الغربيه لتلقي تدريبات عسكريه هناك
للاستعداد للهجوم المضاد يمكن القول حان
الان موعد قطاف يعني ثمار هذا العمل الذي
استمر لاشهر طويله من الحصول على معدات
متطوره دبابات متطوره مثل ليوبار
منظومه صاروخيه وحصلت عليها اوكرانيا بدات
تستخدمها خلال الفتره الماضيه شكرا جزيلا
لك من كيف صحفي محمد البطل
[موسيقى]
خنق وحرق فاباده جحيم بوتين كما يوصف فتح
على الاوكرانيين في اكثر من جبهه منذ
بدايه الحرب فالشمس الحارقه او قاذفات
اللهب الروسيه ثقيله تعد اقوى الاسلحه غير
النوويه في العالم واشدها تدميرا نسخه
محدثه من الرجمات الثقيله وهي اله التوسون
اي عسكريه مجنزره ضخمه فوقها راجمه صواريخ
حراريه فتاكه هذه الصواريخ تستخدم الوقود
والاكسجين من الهواء المحيط لتوليد انفجار
عالي الحراره اي تقذف الرذاذ الجوي لتخلق
بذلك انفجارا حول الهدف وتغطيه بمجال
حراري لا يطاق نيران الشمس الحارقه قادره
على تغطيه مساحه تصل الى 40 كيلومترا
مربعا بقوه نيران هائله وتطلق 24 صاروخا
خلال مده زمنيه لا تتجاوز الست ثواني وفي
جميع الاتجاهات بماذا يصل 6 كم اما
اعدادها للقتال فلا يتعدى تسعين ثانيه
وتنطلق بسرعه تبلغ 60 كيلومترا في الساعه
هذا السلاح الخارق يخنق ضحاياه حتى الموت
ومن المستحيل اختباء من نيرانه حتى في
الخنادق فموسكو تروج للسلاح الفريد بانه
يحول الهواء الى لهب يضيف الاهداف ويبيدها
وبالفعل ليس هناك شبيه لهذه القاذفات في
ترى سنات الغرب العسكريه لكنها لقيت ندها
فالقاذفات التي تحول الليل الى نهار من
شده توهجها ضعيفه الامكانات بمواجهه
الطيران المسير بمختلف في احجامه فالشمس
الحارقه تفوقت على جميع الاسلحه العملاقه
وقهرها السلاح الصغير
[موسيقى]
الخوف وانهزاميه قد يتسللان كما العدو الى
نفوس المقاتلين خوف ممزوج برؤى نهاري عن
اهوال ما يرونه في الحرب القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول تقديم الدعم المناسب
لهؤلاء الجنود عبر توفير مسمته المظله
الروحيه لقوات الخطوط الاماميه وفق صحيفه
جيل تيليجراف ضباط اوكرانيون اكدوا ان
المظله الاساسيه التي تحمي بلادهم هي
القوات المسلحه لكن هؤلاء بدورهم بحاجه
للحمايه النفسيه والمعنويه عشره عسكريين
اوكرانيين تدربوا لاسبوعين على يد الجيش
البريطاني في معسكر بالقرب من لتقديم
الدعم المناسب للجنود المشاركين المشاركون
تعلموا كيفيه تقديم الرعايه والدعم النفسي
والتوجيه المعنوي للجنود في ساحه المعركه
الجيش الاوكراني يضم بالفعل 160 شخصا لهذه
المهمه انضموا الى هيكل القياده العسكريه
منذ ابره للماضي فهؤلاء ياتون من اقسام
مختلفه مثل البحريه والمشاه والقوات
الخاصه والقسم الطبي ايضا واجتازوا اسابيع
من التدريب في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
بعد فوضى تجنيد المدانين مدارس روسيا تغرق
بفوضى تربويه عارمه تحت عنوان عسكره
الاجيال المقبله فالمناهج التعليميه تفيض
بدروس وانشطه لا منهجيه تدعم افكار دعم
الحرب والموضوعات العسكريه والوطنيه كما
تقول نيويورك تايمز هذه الجهود جزء من
حمله الموسعه لتعزيز المحتوى الطبي
العسكري الوطني بجميع المدارس العامه
البالغ عددها اربعين الف مدرسه الجهود
تشمل جميع المستويات من رياض الاطفال الى
الجامعه تهدف لتدريب الاجيال القادمه على
تبديل الجيش وتعزيز روايه بوتين القائله
باندلاع حرب حقيقيه على الوطن الام وفق
تعبيره وتحقيقا لهذه الغايه اعلنت وزاره
التربيه والتعليم والدفاع ان التدريب
العسكري سيكون الزاميا العام المقبل لطلاب
الصف العاشر حيث سيقع على عاتق الفتيات
تعلم الاسعافات الاوليه في ساحه المعركه
فيما يتدرب الاولاد على تشكيل الحفر
والتعامل مع الكلاشنكوف وغيرها علما بان
جهود التلقين بدات بشكل اساسي مع ضم روسيا
لشبه جزيره القرم الاوكرانيه عام 2014 لكن
الحرب الاوكرانيه صرعت الخطط التعليميه
[موسيقى]
طبول الحرب التي دقت لم تصمت بعد لكن
المساومه على اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا بدات
بالفعل فرئيسه اكبر شركه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا نفتوغاز اكد ان اعاده بناء
اوكرانيا ضروريه ليس من باب الرحمه ولكن
من منطلق مصلحه تجاريه عمليه حيث اقر ان
اصلاح البنيه التحتيه للطاقه المحطمه في
البلاد سيكلف المليارات لكن انفاقه تلك
الاموال سيساعد اوروبا على اكمال تحولها
بعيدا عن الطاقه الروسيه وفق تعبيرك فرغم
الحرب تواصل روسيا استخدام شبكه خطوط
الانابيب الضخمه في اوكرانيا لارسال الغاز
الى زبائنها المتضائلين بينهم سلوفاكيا
ومولدوفا فنفاس تهدف الى استبدال الغاز
الذي يتدفق حاليا من روسيا للاتحاد
الاوروبي عبر اوكرانيا بالغاز الاوكراني
لكنه اوكرانيا التي تروج حاليا لنفسها
كبديل لروسيا في تصدير الطاقه الى اوروبا
على يقين هي بان الاستبدال الكامل
للصادرات موسكو من الغاز غير ممكن فخططها
تتمثل بامدادات كافيه لت مؤقته لاحتياجات
اوروبا اثناء انتقالها الى الطاقه الخضراء
علما بان اوكرانيا تمتلك ثاني او ثالث
اكبر احتياطيات وموارد للغاز الطبيعي في
اوروبا والمقدره باكثر من تريليون متر
مكعب من الغاز الطبيعي
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمره ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
الذهب ثروه السودان المحظوره واحد اسباب
حربه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في التاسعه هذا المساوا في
تفاصيلها ايضا توعد الاتحاد الاوروبي
بمحاسبه كافه المسؤولين عن الانتهاكات
والتجاوزات لحقوق الانسان في السودان بعد
رص تجاوزات عده ميدانيا حث الاتحاد
الاوروبي في بيانا حتى الطرفي الصراع في
السودان على وقف الاعمال القتاليه على
الفور وافتح المجال الاستئنافي عمليه
انتقال سياسيا شامل ذات مصداقيه مضيفا ان
العمل متواصل مع جميع الجهات الاقليميه
والدوليه المعنيه بما في ذلك الاتحاد
الافريقي والممثل القاسي الامين العام
للامم المتحده في السودان لتحقيق هذه
الاهداف
اراد موحده وطرقات غارقه بالمياه يتخوف
منها السودانيون مع اقتراب ما يعرف بموسم
الفيضانات فمستنقع المياه المتوقعه سيشد
على يد معارك داميه قطعت سبل المساعدات
الغذائيه والصحيه عن الملايين في هذه
الفتره من كل عام يشهد السودان امطارا
غزيره تحمل معها فيضانات في الاغلب وتستمر
حتى اكتوبر وبالفعل شهد السودان اوله هطور
للامطار وضربت مناطق عده بينها الخرطوم
وايضا اندرمان وحملت معها رياح قويه محمله
بالاتربه وعواصف رعديه بحسب ما افاد مراسل
العربيه منسوب القلق يتزايد من ان تعرقل
هذه الامطار جهود الاغاثه التي تضررت
بالفعل بسبب المعارك المتقطعه والتاخيرات
الناجمه عن الاجراءات البيروقراطيه
والتحديات اللوجستيه لاسيما ان الاف
المدنيين في العاصمه او حتى في اقليم
دارفور يعانون شحا في الكهرباء والمياه
والغذاء وستتعطل اغلب المستشفيات والمرافق
الصحيه هذا وارتفعت المخاوف من زياده
مخاطر الاصابه بالامراض المنقوله عن طريق
المياه
[موسيقى]
ذكريات اليمه من حرب اهليه طاحنه امتدت
سنوات لقيا طريق عودتها الى اذهان اهالي
دارفور لثالث يوم على التوالي تتواصل
اشتباكات الداميه في مدينه كتم الواقعه
على بعد 160 كيلومترا شمال غرب مدينه
الفاشر في دارفور مدينه كتم هي الاخرى
تحولت الى ساحه تجاذب للسيطره بين الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه ففي وقت نفى الجيش
سقوط قطن في قبضه الدعم السريع اكد الاخير
عبر فيديوهات سيطره على حاميه لواء 22 في
كتب فمعارك كنتم تسببت بنزوح 150 الف شخص
من معسكر للنازحين باتجاه القرى المجاوره
اضافه لمقتل 54 شخصا بحسب تقديرات اوليه
كان حاكم الاقليم اعلن المنطقه منكوبه مع
استمرار اعمال النهب والقتل وقد امتدت
للشبكات لتصل الى منطقه كفود ثاني اكبر
مدينه بالمنطقه لتؤجج المخاوف من عوده شبح
حرب اهليه راقدا تحت الرماد بانتظار شراره
لايقاده فالمواجهه المسلحه التي اندلعت
عام 2003 في دارفور بين ميليشيات الجنجويد
والقوات الحكوميه ادت لمقتل 300 الف شخص
وتشريد الملايين
هذا ونفذت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تهديداتها بفرض عقوبات على مجموعه من
الشركات السودانيه التابعه للطرفي الصراع
بالسودان من قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع بعد خرق الهدنه التي ترعاها
وضمت العقوبات اهم الشركات التي تختص
بتعدين وتصدير ذهب شريان الاقتصاد
السوداني
لن يحسموا الصراع في السودان الهيمنه
السياسيه والعسكريه في اقطار البلاد فقط
بل سيكتب مصير استثمارات تقدر بمليارات
الدولارات
ذهبوا احد مفاتيح السودان الكبير واهمها
في تغذيه النزاع الدائري منذ شهر ونصف ليس
جديدا لكنه يتجدد
[موسيقى]
منذ اواخر القرن التاسع عشر بدات الدول
الاستعماريه الكبرى بالبحث عن مصادر
لتمويل حروبها كان السودان لا يزال ارضا
بكرا منجما للعتاد البشري والذهب الاصفر
نعمه تحولت الى نقمه الاطماع الخارجيه
والداخليه لم تتوقف حتى بعد الاستقلال بل
استشرت العام الماضي صدر السودان فقط نحو
ثلث ما ينتجه من الذهب 30 طنا فقط من اصل
100 طن
ذهبت عوائدها الى خزينه الدوله والباقي تم
تهريبه الى الخارج
وبعائدته يمول الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع عددهم العسكريه والبشري
لتشفيف منابع التمويل فرضت واشنطن مؤخرا
عقوبات على شركات اتهمت باذكاء الصراع
السوداني منها شركتان مرتبطتان بالجيش
واخريان تتبعان لقوات الدعم السريع
احداهما تختص في تعدين الذهب اذ يدير قائد
الدعم السريع جزءا كبيرا من مناجم الذهب
كما ان للجيش شركات تدعم التنقيب بحسب
تقرير امريكي في السودان تتوزع مناجم
الذهب في صحاره وجبال شرق نهر النيل وفي
محاذاه البحر الاحمر واعلى سلسله جبال
البحر الاحمر ومناطق جبال النوبه واقليمي
كردفان ودارفور لكن اتساع رقعه الحرب
واستمرارها سيكبد البلد خسائر كبيره تزيد
من متوسط معدلات التضخم التي بلغت نسبتها
700 بالمئه وسيفقده مليارين ونصف المليار
دولار من عائداته المفارقه ان حق تصدير
الذهب لا يمنح الا لشركات اجنبيه تجاوز
عددها ال 400 تستحوذ على نحو 300 كم مربع
من اماكن الامتياز اما البنك المركزي
فيقتصر دوره على عمليات الشراء لبناء
الاحتياطات فقط فيما يقوم الجيش وقوات
الدعم بتامين الحمايه لهذه الشركات
ولشركات اخرى تعمل بشكل غير رسمي على
الاراضي السودانيه كالرمح النووي العربيه
وللحديث اكثر حول هذا الموضوع اذهب الى
ضيفي التاسعه هذا المساء الكريميد من
الرياض محمود العوده الصحفيه السوداني ومن
نيروبي يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع اهلا بكم معنا في
التاسعه هذا محمد أبدا معك مساله تهريب
الذهب ليست بالجديده منذ البشير استاذ
محمود منذ حكومه البشير وحتى حكومه حمدوك
وايضا في الفتره الحاليه وكان الكل يعلم
بالامر ولكن لا احد يفعل شيء لماذا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اشكركم على
استضافه
والتحيه لك والتحيه لضيفك الكريم في
الحقيقه طبعا المساله
الذهب يعني هي مرتبطه تاريخيا طبعا كما
ذكرتم في تاريخكم انه الذهب السوداني
يعتبر بلاد الذهب هذا من القرن الثامن عشر
عندما فكر محمد علي باشا غزوه السودان من
اجل استجلاب الذهب من جبال بني شنقول من
اجل تحقيق امبراطوريه التي كان يحلم بها
يعني من هذه الخلفيه انا اعتقد يعني
الذهب كان محط انظار لكثير من الدول وكثير
من الجهات التي تطمع في ان تستخرج هذه
الثروه الثمينه التي تمثل يعني عائدا
كبيرا في الاسواق العالميه ولكن سبب يعني
التهريب يعني يعود انه اول حاجه لا توجد
قوانين او انظمه تحكم هذه التهريب يعني
بدليل انه السودان لا توجد فرصه للذهب
كمثل
الاسواق الاخرى فبالتالي غياب الانظمه اثر
على على هذا الثروه وبالتالي ايضا توجد
يعني هنالك بعض الجهات الاهليه التي تمارس
عمليه الذهاب يعني يشارك في تنقيب الذهب
اكثر حسب الاحصائيات الموجوده ثلاثه
ملايين شخص منتشرين في المناطق الموجوده
في السودان التي تصل الى 800 موقع للذهب
هؤلاء لا تستطيع الحكومه يعني
نقاط عده ولكن استاذ محمود يعني فقط اسمح
لي هناك دائما كان في اتهامات بحمدتي
وجماعته بالسيطره على الذهب لكن لماذا
الان جمعت الجيش والقوات المسلحه بداوا
بتكثيف هذه الاتهامات طالما ان المعلومات
موجوده منذ مده وفي السابق في زمان البعيد
لماذا الان
طبعا يعني يا اختي الكريمه يعني الظرف
تغير الان في اعتداءات وفي مواجهات عسكريه
فلازم تظهر هذه السلبيات يعني يعني في
السابقه كان في غطاء بحكم الجنرال نفسه
المتنازعان للاثنان يعني هم كانوا يعني
اصدقاء وبالتالي كان كل الاخر يغطي على
على الثاني فبالتالي ظهرت هذه الاشياء
وانا اعتقد انه يعني المساله يعني الشركات
الذهب والشركات الاخرى انا اعتقدهم
متقاسمون في هذه التهمه وبالتالي يعني
اعتقد المساله ليس يعني ببعيده من الطرفان
يعني نذهب الى استاذ يوسف استاذ يوسف هناك
اتهامات بان محمد حمدانو يسيطر على اكبر
مناجم الذهب ويعتبره ملكه ويعتبر بان هذا
هذه الجبال ملكه اليس من المفترض ان تتبع
لدوله وليس لجماعه مسلحه
الحديث عن الذهب
واتهام لا تسببته اي وقائع
استثمار اسره محمد حمدان وليس محمد شخصيا
او العمل في الذهب بشركه الجنات للتعدين
سنه 2005 لم يكن في وقتها هنالك اي دعم
سريع او اي مؤسسه عسكريه او يقودها يعني
هو كون حمدتي نفسه كون ثروته من الذهب ومن
سيطر على جبال الذهب
اين جبال الذهب تمت الدعايه انه محمد
حمدان دقلي يسيطر على جبل عامل جبل عام
ر ممنوع وفقا للوزاره التعدين في توزيع
مربعات الذهب ممنوع لشركه الجنيد وليس
ممنوح للدعم السريع او لمحمد حمدان دبلوك
وهذا المربع حين ذهب الناس في
الاعلان منطقه في شمال دارفور ومنطقه
اجتماعيا تتبع لنا لدينا فيها وجود ولا
يستطيع احد ان يذهب اليها بحكم الصراعات
الموجوده في دارفور
اخذ وبدات التعدين في المنطقه مع وجود
التعدين الاهلي في جبل في جبل عامر لم
تغلق شركه الجنيد الجبل على انه يكون تابع
فقط لها او تمنع الاخرين استاذ محمود
دعني اوضح الفكره قليلا حين بدا بدا
الحديث عن ج تمت اعادته لوزاره الماليه
وتنازلت شركه جنيد عن موضوع عن المربع حتى
وانهم ممنوع لها بالقانون فهذه دعايه اكثر
من انها حقيقه من حق محمد حمدان دقله من
حق اي سوداني نستثمر في الذهب هذه ليست
جريمه يعني طيب خليني اسمع وجهه نظره
استاذ محمود بهذا الخصوص سمعتي الى مقاله
سيد يوسف ما تعليقك تفضل
طيب يعني طبعا ممكن قد تقود في نقاط
خلافيه في هذه المساله طبعا معروف لدى
الجميع انه جبل عامر كان جمل يعني جبل
محتكر لقوات الدعم السريع ولقائد الدعم
السريع وكان لا يقرب احد يعني حسب
الروايات المحليه والتقارير التي نشرت في
السي ان ان ومجلس الشؤون الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى يعني كل هذه
الاشياء تحت تصرف
قائد الدعم السريع وهو الذي يعني بدا
بتاسيس هذه الشركات وطبعا يعني احنا لو
جينا نقارن يعني انتشار وامتداد قوات
الدعم السريع بهذه القوه وتسليحها
وعلاقاته الخارجيه يعني كانت واضحه لها كل
العالم الخارجي يعني حتى في زيارته
الاخيره التي قام بها الى روسيا لمقابله
الرئيس بوتين ولم يستطيع ان يقابلوه في
بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه كانت هنالك
الغربيه تتحدث بانه
الدعم السريع هو الذي مد بوتين
بكميات من الذهب
حتى حتى ولو ان هناك جهه ثالثه تقوم
بالذهب صحيح
الذهب بالاساسيه تتبع للحكومه يعني كما
يتعلق العملات يعني ممكن ممكن ممكن اذكر
لك نقطه مهمه جدا بعد انقلاب اكتوبر انا
اعتقد المصارعان الان كانوا وقعوا
اتفاقيات مع روسيا بتمديد روسيا بالذهب
يعني هذا بالذات بعد انقلاب
انقلاب 25 اكتوبر 20 21 وحتى في شركه
بنقرا الروسيه يعني توسعت في نشاطها في
كافه
بعض المناطق بالذات في منطقه البحر الاحمر
وقناه السي ان ان نشرتوا هذا التقرير
ويعني مراسلتها جابت تقرير متكامل بالرغم
انه كذب هذا التقرير ولكن طبعا هو تزامن
مع الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه وبالتالي
طلعت هذه هذه الاسرار فبالتالي انا اعتقد
مساله يعني مساله انه يعني ابتعاد يعني
قوات يعني الدعم السريع من مساله انه هي
مسيطره على الذهب انا اعتقد هذه حقيقه غير
صحيحه وحتى كمان في اثناء وجود كانت هنالك
كميات من الذهب تهرب عن طريق مطار الخرطوم
نهارا ونهارا الى الى دور لو سمحتي الى
دول الى دول بعينها وكانت يعني اصابع
الاتهام موجهه الى
الدعم السريع يعني وحتى يعني احنا نكون
واضحين من اين هذه الايه التجهيزات
الاسلحه للقوات الدعم الدعم السريع وحتى
يعني صحيفه كانت يعني اصدر التقرير او نشر
التقرير قالت انه الفرق بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات نستعمل السريع هي تتمثل في
انه رواتب الدعم السريع هي رواتب عاليه
اذا قارنتها يعني بجنود الجيش السوداني
وهذا يعني انه يعني استفاد استثماريا من
هذه الثروه الهائله يعني شكرا جزيلا طيب
يا استاذ يوسف يعني استمعت الى مقاله
استاذ محمود واليوم يعني عندما تتحدث كل
الوكالات العالميه ان كان اغلبها عن فكره
حمايه شركه فاجنر لقوات الدعم السريع
وحمايه حمتي وايضا ارتباط قوات الدعم
السريع بشركات روسيه فيما يتعلق بالذهب
الا يثير ذلك بعض الشبهات ويقطع الشك
باليقين
هذه وقائع يمكن الترابط بينها بزياره محمد
حمدان التي ذكرها اخونا في انه لان روسيا
وانها الغرض منها هو تحالف كانه شخصي او
بان قوات الدعم السريع وبالروسيا هذه
الزياره تمت في شهر 2 2022
بموافقه مجلس السياده وذهب محمد حمدان
دقلو كنائب لرئيس مجلس السياده مع كل
الوزراء وزياره رسميه وزياره دوله ما يربط
السودان بروسيا علاقات تاريخيه
الدبلوماسيه موجوده ولا يمنع لا يوجد اي
شيء يمنع اي اي قائد سوداني او اي شخص
ممثل للدوله نسب وما زالت العلاقات بين
روسيا والسودان علاقات عاديه اما ما يخص
غيره هذه دعايه جميع يعرف انه شركات في
السودان هي تحت
كفاله وزاره الدفاع شركات في السودان وهذه
حقائق مثبته وموجوده وتكون جميع حتى الفيز
الدخول للخروج هي شركات معروفه وموجوده
تحت وزاره الدفاع تشرف عليها وزاره الدفاع
عند العقد الاول كانت لديها عرض في زمن
البشير لتدريب القوات المسلحه والدعم
السحريه كانت جزء من القوات المسلحه هذه
مساله معروفه للعالم معروفه لاي طرف
قائد الدعم السريعه وقوات الدعم السريع
تحت حمايه اتفقنا تثبته الوقائع وهذا
الدعم السريع هي التي يمكن ان تحمي في
السودان وليس تحتاج حمايه من الخرطوم هي
لديها القدره على على الصمود لمده 50 يوم
تسيطر على كل الخرطوم لديها القدره على
الدفاع عن نفسها فما الذي يتطبع لحمايه من
باب ولا يوجد قوات اصلا على الارض لكي
تقدم اي حمايه هذه هذه حديثه جدا
للحديث تتمه ولكن انتهى الوقت شكرا جزيلا
لكما يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع واشكر ايضا محمود لعوته
الصحفي السوداني شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
بعد جائحه كورونا وما رافقها من تداعيات
اقتصاديه قاسيه تراجعت اسهم شركات
تكنولوجيا وبدات تفقدوا بريقها وموظفيها
معا نستطيع القول لانها دخلت غرفه الانعاش
في الاشهر الاخيره وكثير منها بدا مرحله
الاحتضار الى ان تدخل الذكاء الاصطناعي
ومنحها قبله الحياه وقادها لفتره وجيزه
الى طفره هائله اصبح من المستحيل تقريبا
تجاهلها او الهروب منها فذكاء الاصطناعي
هو المجال الوحيد الذي مازال يجذب موظفين
جدد بوادي السيليكون كما تقول واشنطن بوست
فتقرير بيانات شركه بيتش بوك المتخصصه ان
راس المال المستثمر في هذا النوع من
الشركات زاد سته وثمانين في المئه عن ذات
الشهر من العام الماضي الاسبوع الماضي
اصبحت شركه انفيديا التي تصنع رقائق ذكيه
اصبحت واحده من عدد قليل من الشركات في
العالم التي بلغت قيمتها تريليون دولار
واشنطن بوست ترى ان اندفاع شركات
الاستثمار في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي جاء
بعد اطلاق شركه اوبن اي اي لبرنامج
الروبوت الذكي دفع شركات تكنولوجيا
العملاقه مثل مايكروسوفت وجوجل لدخول
السباق وبالمقارنه بينما تم استثماره في
شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا العام وما
استثمر سابقا نجد الفجوه هائله فاثنى عشر
فاصله خمسه مليار دولار تم استثمارها هذا
العام حتى الان مقارنه باربعه فاصله خمسه
مليار دولار فقط تم استثمارها في هذا
المجال عام 2022
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى شيكاغو ومعنا عبر سكايب الدكتور
طارق رفاعي رئيس التنفيذي لمركز كورم
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه دكتور طارق اهلا
بكم معنا في التاسع هذا المساء هل بات من
الضروري للشركات التكنولوجيا ان تتكيف مع
الذكاء الاصطناعي فبدونه لن تصمد
طبعا هذه اللي شفناه اليوم الاستثمار
القوي وحتى استثمار سريع في هذه القطاع
احنا شفنا على سبيل المثال الطفره الاخيره
عندما طرحت العملات الرقميه وشفنا
الاندلاع السريع من قبل الكثير من الشركات
نحو هذا المحور الجديد والان نرى نفس
التحول اتجاه الذكاء الصناعي
طيب اليوم اذا ما تحدثنا عن الذكاء
الاصطناعي دكتور طارق كان في اتهامات مثلا
في السابق
بتاثير على الناخبي بريطانيا وحتى في
امريكا اليوم من سيحمينا نحن كمستخدمين
وكبشر من الشركات التكنولوجيا التي بدات
توظف الذكاء الاصطناعي
دائما لما نسمع في تكنولوجيا دائما نسمع
عن المخاطر وكذلك يعني حتى الى النص كان
يحذر وحتى اليوم يحذر من طرح الذكاء
الصناعي بهذه السرعه من غير يعني حط ضوابط
والقيود على هذه التكنولوجيا فهذه عليه
علامه استفهام الى الان كيف سنحاول كيف
سنحمي يعني
الاشخاص او الافراد من هذه التكنولوجيا
طيب دكتور طارق من الشركات التكنولوجيه
التي تتكون ستكون المستفيد اكبر من الذكاء
الاصطناعي على حساب غيرها
انت ذكر قوي جدا
ولكن
مثل مايكروسوفت وبالاخص فيسبوك
وحتى جوجل هدول الثلاثه من اكبر شركات
التكنولوجيا ومن سنين كثيره وهم يستثمرون
ويطورون الذكاء صناعي والان مع بدايه هذه
الطفره نلاحظ اداء القوي لهذا الشركات
وحتى يعني الاستثمار في الشركات الناشئه
في هذه القطاعات اكيد يعني سنلاحظ يعني
استثمارات في هذه القطاع من قبل هذه
الشركات شكرا جزيلا
لك كاجو دكتور
[موسيقى]
طارق اقل من ثلاثه اشهر امام تويتر
للتغريد في السماء الاوروبيه فقرار المنصه
بالخروج من مدونه ممارسات التضليل الاتحاد
الاوروبي قد يفقدها احد ابرز جمهورها
لاسيما انها تشكل ابرز المنصات في تشكيل
الراي العام الاوروبي
قبل بضعه ايام وبتغريده من ثلاث كلمات
حذرت نائبه رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه للقيم
والشفافيه تويتر من الحظر في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قائله وداعا ايها الطائر تحذير
يبدو انه قريب من التطبيق بحق الطائر
الازرق
لقد اختار تويتر الطريقه الصعب اختار
المواجهه من خلال الخروج من مدونه ممارسات
التضليل الاوروبيه الطبيعيه التي تضع
القواعد الاساسيه لقانون الاتحاد بشان
الخدمات الرقميه المدونه التي اعلنت تويتر
نيته الانسحاب منها كان الاتحاد الاوروبي
قد اطلقها عام 2018 حيث ستدخل حيز التنفيذ
في 25 من اغسطس لاجبار المنصات على مكافحه
المعلومات المضلله اذ تنص على وجه الخصوص
بوجوب ازاله المحتوى غير القانوني وحظر
الاعلانات التي تستهدف القاصرين وبفرض
غرامات تصل الى سته في المئه من حجم
الاعمال على المنصات التي لا تم هذه
القواعد
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتبر المدونه بمثابه
ميثاق لمكافحه المعلومات المضلله في
الفضاء الالكتروني حيث وقع عليه ما يقرب
من 30 موقعا من بينها مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الكبرى مثل ميتا وتويتر وتيك
توك الى جانب جوجل ومايكروسوفت التهديد
بالحظر لم يكن الاول على لسان جروفا فقد
سبقها الى ذلك الوزير الفرنسي المفوض
للشؤون الرقميه الا ان الاخير اعرب عن
قلقه بشان التنظيم الاوروبي المفرط في
مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي في المستقبل معتبرا
موقف البرلمان الاوروبي مبالغا فيه لكونه
يفرض التزامات تدقيق والتزامات شفافيه
مفرطه بالنسبه لهذا النوع من النماذج وبين
التهديد بالحظر وتطبيقه قرابه الثلاثه
اشهر امام الطائر الازرق للتغريد في
السماء الاوروبيه تغريد ان سكت سيؤثر على
نقاشات الراي العام بحسب الوزير الفرنسي
لكن الم علومات المضلله تهديد للديمقراطيه
الاوروبيه
السعاده المساء مستمره ونتابع
في اول مترشحين رسميا لراسات 20 24 عن
الحزب الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
ذكريات طفوله لو وفتها عدسات كاميرات
تسللت لمراهقه صاخبه بعدها هي قضيه العصر
قعد فيها الامير هاري فتحه كتابي مذكراته
ثلاث وثلاثون قصه خبريه من اصل 147
ستبحثها المحكمه في قضيه انتهاك الصحافه
لخصوصيه الامير الشاب فذوق قدم دعاءات عده
ضد صحف ديلي مرر وسندي مرر ودبيبل لجمعهم
اخبار بطرق غير قانونيه بين
1996 و 2010 اولها يعود الى احتفاله بعيد
ميلاده الثاني عشر حين تحدثت جيل مرر عن
حزن والدته لعدم تمضيه الوقت الكافي معه
وعدم تقبله لتلاقي والدين المدرسه ملاعبها
المراهقه الحفلات علاقات الامير الشاب
وشؤون داخليه اخرى كخلافاته مع شقيقه ضمن
القصص التي سيقدمها نجل ملك بريطانيا قصص
تجادل صاحب بريطانيه بانها كانت مطروحه
للعامه وليست خاصه او سريه مقدمه سردا
بديلا عن كيفيه نشرها فيما يؤكد الامير
هاري ان مثل هذه القصص يمكن ربطها بسجلات
المدفوعين لمحققين خاصين وادله ظرفيه تثبت
استهداف هاتفه واختراق رسائله الصوتيه
[موسيقى]
نذهب الان الى لندن ومعنا من هناك مصطفى
زاهر ومراسل عربيه مصطفى اهلا بك معنا في
التاسع هذا المساء كان اليوم هو اليوم
المنتظر فلماذا غاب ولم يحضر الامير هاري
حقيقه كانت مفاجاه وفوجئ القاضي المحكمه
عندما ابلغ فريق الدفاع عن الصحف
بان سيتم تسريع مرافعاتهم في الجلسه
الافتتاحيه لفتح المجال لاستجواب الامير
هاري وفجاه خرج
المحامي الامير هذه بان بسبب سفره المتاخر
مساء امس من لوسانجلس
وبسبب حضوره حفل ميلاد ابنته ليليبتس
الحفل الميلادي الثاني يعني لم يستطع
الامير هاري ان يكون حاضرا في جلسه
الافتتاحيه بسبب الرحله الطويله
والاعراض التي عاده ما ترافق المسافر في
هكذا رحلات هذا كان مفاجئا ولكن القاضي
الان سيمنح المزيد من الوقت
الفريق
الدفاع
لاستجواب الامير هذه فيما يتعلق بالقصص
والاخبار التي تم نشرها ويتم التركيز فقط
مثل ما ذكرتي على 33 مقالا نشرتها صحف
وايضا
وبالتالي
الانظار تتجه غدا
لمثول الامير هاري كاول شاهد من افراد
العائله الملكه في المملكه المتحده منذ
اكثر من قرن من الزمان
يتفاعل مع قضيه العصر كما تسمى سواء سلبا
ام ايجابا
حقيقه يعني منذ بدء فضيحه
التسريب هذه الاخبار المتعلقه بالعائله
المالكه وخاصه بعد
المقابله المثيره عندما افصح هو وزوجته
بان كانت هناك ادعاءات عنصريه داخل القصر
الملكي بدات شعبيته تتراجع شيئا فشيئا
واخر الاستطلاعات اطلعت عليها من قبل بان
الامير هاري وزوجته تراجعت شعبيتهما الان
في حدود 22% فقط عمه الامير اندرو هو يعني
الاسوء شعبيه في البلاد وبالتالي هناك حتى
من قبل هذه الفئه التي كانت تدعم ما بين
18 عاما و اربعه وثلاثين عاما كانوا يعني
يؤيدونه عندما خرج ويريد ان يفصح عن بعض
التفاصيل داخل القصر لكن يبدو ان هذه
التصريحات
ومذكراته التي نشرت يعني كشفت عن العديد
من الاسرار ربما اضرت به اكثر من
هذا شعبيته
مصطفى بالحديث عن الاسرار هل يمكن ان
تتكشف اسرار اخرى في هذه المحاكمه مثلا
نسمع عن اشخاص يدخلون على الخط في
المستقبل وبالتالي يصبح جزءا من هذه
القضيه في المستقبل القريب واخبار جديده
لم نكن ندري عنها
حقيقه هذا ما تخشاه الدوائر المقربه من
القصر الملكي وحتى الملك تشارلز الثالث
الان ليس في البلد في اجازه في رومانيا
بالاضافه الى ان شقيقه ولي ولي العهد
الامير وليم لا نعرف ما اذا كان هو ايضا
في البال لكن بالتاكيد ليست هناك اي
ترتيبات للقاء احد افراد العائله الملكه
ولكن الخشيه الان وخصوصا وان فريق الدفاع
الصحف الميرور يعني مصر على ان يستغل يعني
مثله وشهادته
لطرح العديد من الاسئله ربما ستثير الكثير
من
الاخبار المرافقه لهذه لهذه المرافعه
التاريخيه لابن لابن الملك
وربما سيكشف اسرارا اخرى اذا ما ارغم على
التاكيد او نفي او اعطاء تفاصيل تتعلق
بشخصيته تتعلق بتعامله ايضا مع بعض
الشخصيات وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالتقارير او
الاخبار التي تم نشرها على مدى عقدين من
الزمن بخصوص الامير هاري وزوجته الميغان
ومراسل العربيه من لندن
[موسيقى]
قدم ماي بنس نائب رئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب قدم رسميا اوراقه ترشحي
لرئاسه الامريكيه عام 20 24 كان بانس اعلن
بوقت سابق نيته الترشح عن الحزب الجمهوري
ليكون منافسا لرئيس السابق
يهنئ زعيمه كوريا الشماليه بانضمام بلاده
للمجلس التنفيذي للصحه العامه التهنئه لم
تمر بسلام على الرئيس السابق فعاصفه من
الانتقادات الحاده هبت بوجهه مصدرها
منافسوه الجمهوريون
نائب ترامب السابق قال انه لا ينبغي لاحد
ان يمدحور كوريا الشماليه يجب ان نوضح
للعالم اننا ندافع عن الحريه ونقف الى
جانب من يدافعون عنها اما نيكي هيلي التي
شغلت في السابق منصبه حاكمه ولايه ساف
كارولاينا وسفيره لدى الامم المتحده فقالت
نحن لا نهنئ سفاحا هدد امريكا وحلفائها
وطبعا يترك الفرصه تفلت من يديه وعبر عن
صدمته لرؤيه التهنئه ووصف كيم جونغ اون
بالديكتاتور القاتل
[موسيقى]
انتقادات لاذعه بين الجمهوريين في سباق
الرئاسه الامريكي هذه المره مصدرها ليست
ترامب نيكي هيلي المرشحه الجمهوريه تطلق
الاتهامات بحق منافسيها الجمهوريين الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وحاكم فلوريدا
رونديسانس قائله انهما ليس صادقين مع
الشعب هيلي اعتبرت ان كل من ترامب وديسانس
قال انهما لن يتعامل مع اصلاح الاستحقاقات
لكن كل ما يفعلانه هو ترك الامر للرئيس
المقبل الامر الذي يجعل الكثير من
الامريكيين في مازق على حد قولها
على العكس ترامب بدا يغير من سياسته
واسلوبه الهجومي بعض الشيء وغدا يركز على
الافكار بدلا من الحرب الكلاميه على خصومه
فقد تحدث عن افكاره تجاه ملفات عده بينها
الاستقلال في مجال الطاقه والتغيير
المطلوب في برامج التعليم
وحذر الجمهوريين من تجنب اجراء اي تغييرات
فوريه على برامج الرعايه الطبيه او الضمان
الاجتماعي على الرغم من ان ادارته كانت
تخطط بالفعل لخفض مزايا قسائم الطعام قبل
ان يمنع القاضي هذه الخطوه في اكتوبر 2020
اما حاكم فلوريدا روندسانس فنعت ترامب
مؤخرا بالمحتال اكثر من مره ووصفه بانه
يسير على نهج عنوانه ان قياده معسكر
الجمهوريين تتطلب قدرا من التنمر والهجوم
السياسيه كانت ترامب دعم ترشح اديسانس
كحاكم لولايه فلوريدا لكن سرعان ما تغيرت
العلاقه بين الرجلين
ويعول الديسانس على ان يظهر بصوره مختلفه
امام الناخبين وهي انه الحرس الجديد لحزب
الجمهوريين بمواجهه ترامب
التصمم يتسلل الى اجساد الافغانيات معيدا
الى المشهد ما حدث في الجاره الايرانيه
طوال اشهر 80 تلميذه افغانيه تعرضنا الى
التسمم في حادثتين منفصلتين في مدرستين
ابتدائتين تقع المدرسه في منطقه سان الشرك
في ولايه
شمالي افغانستان وهما قريبتان من بعضهما
البعض مسؤول باداره التعليم اكد ان الشخص
الذي دبر عمليه التسمم كان لديه احقادا
شخصيه دون الخوض في تفاصيله هويته او
اعمار الفتيات اللواتي تسممنا يذكر انها
المره الاولى التي تشهد افغانستان هذا
النوع من الاعتداءات منذ وصول حركه طالبان
الى السلطه قبل عامين لكن حوادث مماثله
اجتاحت البلاد عام 2009 وتحديدا بالشمال
عشرات الطالبات نقلنا حينها للمستشفيات
اثرى استنشاقهن غازا غامضا الان نذهب معكم
الى هذه العواجل التي تتابعونها اسفل
الشاشه رغم
يتراجعوا في اليابان عدد السكان للعام
الثاني عشر على التوالي الحكومه وضعت خطه
لصرف 25 مليار دولار سنويا لتشجيع الانجاب
بعد تراجع معدل الخصوبه الى واحد فاصله
اثنين بالعشره
اعتقد ان الحكومه يجب ان تقلل من ضغط
تربيه الاطفال وان تقدم لنا المزيد من
الدعم يجب ان يستثمروا اكثر في موارد
التعليم في الوقت الحاضر لا يرغب الكثير
من الناس في انجاب الاطفال اذا لم يكن
لديهم الموارد لتوفير تعليم جيد لهم
اذا بقي الامر على حاله سينخفض عدد سكان
اليابان خلال الاربعين سنه القادمه من 125
مليونا الى سبعه وثمانين مليار نسمه
والامر لا ينحصر فقط في اليابان
صحيفه تحذر من عواقب اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
وخيمه سكان الكوكب سيتراجعون مع نهايه
القرن وذلك للمره الاولى منذ تفشي الطاعون
الاسود في القرن الرابع عشر
العديد من
البرج الصين واليابان وسنغافوره وتايوان
كانوا يحاولون اشياء مختلفه لتحقيق معدل
نمو اعلى في عدد السكان كان هذا من خلال
الحوافز الماليه لانجاب الاطفال لكن هذه
الامور لم تكن فعاله مثل ما رايناه في بعض
البلدان الاخرى مثل المانيا وبعض الدول
الاوروبيه في اكبر خمسه عشره دوله في
العالم منها الصين والهند والولايات
المتحده عدد من يموتون سنويا يتجاوز عدد
من يولدون
تراجعت معدلات الخصوبه مع بدايه الالفيه
الجديده من 2.7 الى 2.3 واذا وصلت الى
اثنين في العشره اي كل زوجين ينجبان طفلين
فقط فهذا يعني ان البشر سيبداون في
التناقص
في مشهد غير اعتيادي شهدت مدينه الباحه
جنوب غرب السعوديه تساقطا للثلوج رغم
اقتراب موسم الصيف الحار نتابع
[موسيقى]
في نهايه التاسعه لم يبقى الا ان نذكر
بالعناوين
هجمات اوكرانيه على محاور الشرق كيف تتحدث
عن تقدم وموسكت تؤكد واحباطها
[موسيقى]
بعد واشنطن عقوبات اوروبيه قريبه وخطر
الفيضانات يزيد متاعب السودانيين
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي يستقطب اكثر من 12 مليار
دولار باتجاه خزائن شركات التكنولوجيا
انتهت ولكن اخبارنا بالتاكيد مستمره بعد
قليل طاهر بركه 360 في ساعه اخباريه
مختلفه مساء الخير جدا
ودائما
طبعا نحن سنتابع في الحديث عن اخر
التطورات الروسيه مع الهجمات السيبرانيه
والعسكريه اضافه الى الحديث عن الازمات
التي تلاحق تويتر في امريكا واوروبا ونفتح
ملف الاتفاق النووي الايراني ونستضيف
ضيفينا الكريمين من طهران لنبين وجهه
النظر الايرانيه في ذلك ومن واشنطن لنبين
وجهه النظر الامريكيه كوني معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات